la asamblea nacional resolvió en juicial
al presidente de la república Guillermo
lasso para seguir con el proceso se
necesitaba una votación de mayoría
simple esto es la mitad más uno de los
asambleístas presentes en la sala el
pleno alcanzó los votos y posteriormente
aprobó el llamado a juicio político la
acusación inicial fueron supuestos
delito de peculado las acusaciones están
relacionadas con la firma de un contrato
de la flota petrolera ecuatoriana para
el transporte de petróleo que causaron
el perjuicio del estado con el supuesto
conocimiento al presidente según los
asambleístas la convocatoria tuvo lugar
luego de que no se alcanzaran los votos
en la comisión de fiscalización a favor
de un informe no vinculante que no
recomendaba el juicio político al
mandatario el presidente del parlamento
anunció que al no haber un texto
aprobado no existe un informe y lo
desarrollado no tenía efecto jurídicos
una vez reunidos los votos la asamblea
nacional deberá continuar con el juicio
político al presidente de la república
se deben cumplir con plazos de ley para
convocar a la sesión y llamar así la
votación según los tiempos legales la
sesión se podría realizar entre el 14 y
el 16 de mayo